ENEMY, THINK HANNITY NOW.
>> THINK YOU, WELCOME TO ANY.
BUCKLE UP.
TONIGHT, DON'T DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THEY ARE ON THE VERGE OF AN
ALL-OUT CIVIL WAR.
NANCY PELOSI HAS LOST COMPLETE
CONTROL OF HER RADICAL SOCIALIST
BASE.
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN, A CASIO
CORTEZ, CONGRESSWOMAN TO LEAVE
AND OMAR AND IONIC PRESLEY ARE
NOW RUNNING THE SHOW.
SPEAKER PELOSI IS NOW TOTALLY
POWERLESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY SHE EVEN HAS
THE GAVEL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS WEIGHED IN
AND NOW, THIS FAKE PHONY MORAL
SELECTIVE OUTRAGE
LEFT, THEY ARE IN FULL GEAR.
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
TONIGHT WE WILL BREAK IT ALL
DOWN.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL HANNITY
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE
FANATICAL LEADERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LAST WEEK, THE GLOVES CAME OFF
BETWEEN CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRA
CASIO CORTEZ AND SPEAKER PELOSI.
AND IF YOU WOULD THEN BOILED
OVER DURING AN INTERVIEW WHEN A
CASIO CORTEZ SUGGESTED
NANCY PELOSI IS A RACIST.
I'VE BEEN SAYING, SHE IS
NANCY PELOSI, SPEAK IN NAME
ONLY, AND WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT ALL
ALONG.
AOC IS ATTACK LAST WEEK CAME
IMMEDIATELY AFTER PELOSI TOLD
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE
CAUCUS TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS
DIRECTLY TO HER.
FACE-TO-FACE.
NOT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHAT DID A CASIO CORTEZ DO?
SHE WENT STRAIGHT TO
SOCIAL MEDIA SO THE QUESTION IS,
WHO REALLY HAS THE POWER?
MEANWHILE, AOC'S CLOSE FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE, CONGRESSWOMAN
AYANNA PRESSLEY WANTS TO RACIAL
ATTACK AGAINST PELOSI'S ALLIES,
EVEN SUMMONING THE CONGRESSIONAL
BLACK CAUCUS.
WATCH THIS.
>> TO ALL OF YOU THAT HAS
ASPIRATIONS OF RUNNING FOR
OFFICE, FOR WHATEVER LYTIC
EXPERIENCE AND IDENTITY THAT YOU
REPRESENT, IF YOU ARE NOT
PREPARED TO COME TO THAT STABLE
AND TO REPRESENT THAT VOICE,
DON'T COME.
BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED ANY MORE
BROWN FACES THAT DON'T WANT TO
BE A GROUND VOICE BUT WE DON'T
NEED BLACK FACES BUT DON'T WANT
TO BE A BLACK VOICE.
WE DON'T NEED MUSLIMS THAT DON'T
WANT TO BE A MUSLIM VOICE.
WE DON'T NEED THAT DON'T WANT TO
BE A CLEAR VOICE.
>> Hannity: TONIGHT, DOES NOT
MATTER WHAT SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS,
WHAT SHE DOES.
THE RADICALS ARE IN CHARGE.
ANYONE WHO OPPOSES THEM, OF
COURSE, QUICKLY LABELED
XENOPHOBIC, HOMOPHOBIC AND
LONELY, LAWS OF ISLAM US WILL
BECOME A RACIST, EVERYTHING
GREAT THE SO-CALLED SQUAD OF FAR
LESS CONGRESSWOMAN ARE NOW USING
IDENTITY POLITICS EVEN AGAINST
MEMBERS OF THEIR OWN PARTY.
THE END GOAL IS TO FUNDAMENTALLY
RESHAPE AMERICA.
THAT'S WITHIN THREE NEW DEAL IS
ALWAYS ABOUT.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE,
IT'S NOT ABOUT SAVING THE
ENVIRONMENT.
NOT AT ALL.
AND SO ITS PRIMARY PURPOSE IS TO
MOVE THE ECONOMY AWAY FROM
CAPITALISM AND FREE MARKET
OPPORTUNITY AND A SOCIETY THAT
PAYS OFF RISK AND REWARD TOWARDS
SOCIALISM.
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT CONTROLS
ALL OF THE MEANS OF PRODUCTION.
AOC OF ACETIC AND WE WILL TELL
YOU HOW TO RUN YOUR BUSINESS AND
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE THE
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR A
OCASIO CORTEZ, LOOK AT THIS,
RECENTLY'S EYE, THE INTERESTING
THING ABOUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL IS THAT IT WASN'T
ORIGINALLY A CLIMATE CHANGE
THING AT ALL.
I'M RIGHT.
NOW, SOME HOUSE DEMOCRATS
SOUNDING THE ALARM AND THEY ARE
CIRCULATING A POLL SHOWING THAT
ONLY 18% OF KEY VOTERS IN SWING
DISTRICTS HAVE A FAVORABLE VIEW
OF SOCIALISM.
THAT SAME POLL REVEALS THAT ONLY
22% HAVE A FAVORABLE VIEW OF
CONGRESSWOMAN O OCASIO CORTEZ
AND BY THE WAY, ONLY 9% APPROVAL
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR.
STILL, AS WE SPEAK, THE BASE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SO
POWERFUL THAT EVERY 2020 HOPEFUL
HAS ADOPTED THEIR FRINGE
SOCIALIST POLICIES AND IF THEY
DON'T ADOPT IT COMPLETELY, THEY
ARE TRASHED BY MANY ON THE
FLOOR.
AT A MEDICARE FOR ALL,
TAXPAYER-FUNDED HEALTH CARE FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, OH, YEAH, NO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION AT ALL,
EVEN DURING BIRTH OR IN SOME
CASES AFTER BIRTH.
AND FANS ASIDE.
END OF COURSE, THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
NO MORE OIL, NO MORE GAS, NO
MORE COMBUSTION ENGINES,
EVENTUALLY, WE GET RID OF PLANES
AND COUNTS AND BY THE WAY,
EVERYTHING IS GUARANTEED.
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME.
THE JOB, HIGHER EDUCATION,
RETIREMENT, YOU NAME IT, THEY
WILL PROVIDE A PAIR THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON.
AND WITH EACH CRAZY NEW POLICY,T
AND WITH EACH CRAZY NEW POLICY,E
CANDIDATES ARE JUST DIGGING
IN DEEPER AND DEEPER HOLE IT FOR
THE GENERAL ELECTION IN 2020
BEARD WHILE WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THIS COUNTRY IS NOT
PERFECT, WE ALL AGREE THAT WE
ARE NOT PERFECT PEOPLE.
THERE ARE NO PERFECT PEOPLE ON
THIS EARTH.
WE WANT OUR LEADERS TO WORK
TOWARDS IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
ALL AMERICANS.
LET'S NOT FORGET, IT WAS THIS
COUNTRY COME OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THE
SINGLE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH, WE PAID THE PRICE FOR
FREEDOM DEFEATING FASCISM, AND
NAZISM, COMMUNISM, IMPERIAL
JAPAN, AND WE ARE NOW LEADING
THE WAR, FIGHTING RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERRORIST.
AND BY THE WAY, WE HAVE
CONTRIBUTED AS PIETY MORE TO
HUMANITY AND THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THE HUMAN CONDITION.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR LESS.
THERE IS NO COUNTRY THAT IS
GIVEN MORE AND ASKED FOR LESS
THAN THE USA.
AND WE DON'T NEED TO BE FUN TO
EVENTUALLY TRASH TRANSFORMED.
SADLY, RADICAL DEMOCRATS
BELIEVED VERY DIFFERENT.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE, CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR, FORMER REFUGEE FROM
WAR-TORN SOMALIA.
IT CONGRESSWOMAN OUT OMAR
RECENTLY SAID SHE PROBABLY LOVES
THIS COUNTRY MORE THAN THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE BORN HERE.
OKAY, CONGRESSWOMAN, IF THAT'S
TRUE, YOU HAVE A PRETTY STRANGE
WAY OF SHOWING IT.
IN FACT, DURING THOSE SAME
REMARKS, SHE ACCUSED AMERICA
THAT WE ARE NOT LIVING UP TO OUR
REPUTATION.
REALLY?
THANK YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE EXPLORED AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
THE GREAT AMERICA.
THE LAND OF LIBERTY AND JUSTICE,
THAT IS, YOU KNOW, YOU ASK
ANYBODY IN WALKING ON THE SIDE
OF THE STREET SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WORLD, THEY WILL
TELL YOU, AMERICA THE GRADE.
BUT DON'T LIVE THOSE VALUES
HERE.
>> Hannity: THIS IS NOT ONE
ISOLATED COMMENT.
OMAR ROUTINELY TRASHES THIS
COUNTRY AND SOMETIMES RESORTING
TO THE CONSPIRACY THEORY AS WELL
TO DO SO.
SHE ONCE CLAIMED THAT A MIC AND
SOLDIERS SLAUGHTERED THOUSANDS
OF SOMALIANS DURING A BLACK HAWK
DOWN CRISIS.
THE TRUTH?
THE REALITY?
AMERICAN SOLDIERS WERE KILLED,
HUNDREDS OF MILITANTS LITERALLY
DURING A CLASH WITH A VIOLENT
WARLORD WHO HAD ATTACKED U.N.
PEACEKEEPERS.
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
OMAR ALSO CLAIMED THAT THE U.S.
WAS TO BLAME FOR THE TERRORIST
ATTACK IN KENYA.
AND SHE SAID THE U.S. BULLYING,
NOT SOCIALISM, LED TO THE
DEVASTATION IN VENEZUELA.
SHE ALSO CALLED FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA EVEN A PRETTY
FACE WHO GOT AWAY WITH MURDER
BECAUSE OF HIS USE OF DRONES.
AND TODAY, SHE ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF CAUSING THE
DEATHS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
OH?
HOW DID HE DO THAT?
THIS ADDS TO THE LIST OF WHY
PEOPLE PSYCHOTICALLY,
IMPULSIVELY HATE DONALD TRUMP
FOR NO PARTICULARLY REASON AND
REALITY OR ROOTED IN REALITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO IS
OVERSEEING THE MOST CORRUPT
ADMINISTRATION IN OUR HISTORY.
AND PURSUED AN END DUE TO AN
AGENDA THAT A LOT OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS TO DIE FROM A LACK
OF HEALTH CARE WHILE HE
TRANSFERS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAX CUTS TO CORPORATIONS.
THROUGH AND ALSO AS YOU KNOW,
CONGRESSWOMAN OUT OMAR HAS
FREQUENTLY USED ANTI-SEMITIC
RELATIONSHIP TO BASH AMERICA'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR NUMBER ONE
ALLEY IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
ISRAEL.
THE ONLY DEMOCRACY IN THE
REGION.
NOT LONG AGO SHE CLAIMED THAT
OUR CLOSE TIES TO THE WORLD'S
ONLY U.S. STATE, ALL ABOUT THE
BENJAMIN'S.
THEN TWEETED ONCE, QUOTE,
"ISRAEL HAS HYPNOTIZED THE
WORLD.
MAY ALL AWAKEN THE PEOPLE AND TO
HELP THEM SEE THE EVIL DOINGS OF
ISRAEL."
THE CONGRESSWOMAN FREQUENTLY
USES SHOCKING LANGUAGE ABOUT THE
CONCH COUNTRY AND OUR ALLIES,
SHE'S CONSTANTLY MINIMIZING THE
HORRORS OF TERRORISM.
REMEMBER HER TIME AS A STATE REP
IN MINNESOTA, SHE ASKED THE
JUDGE TO GRANT LENIENCY TO NINE
MEN ACCUSED OF TRYING TO JOIN
ISIS.
YET, THOSE PEOPLE HAVE GOT OTHER
PEOPLE'S HEADS OFF, MURDERING,
TERRORIST, YEAH.
DURING A BIZARRE INTERVIEW IN
2013, SHE COULD NOT CONTAIN HER
LAUGHTER WHEN TALKING ABOUT
AL QAEDA, HAS BELOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EVERY TIME THAT THE
PROFESSORS SAID AL QAEDA, HIS
SHOULDERS WENT AL QAEDA, YOU
KNOW.
WE ARE NOT SAYING HIS NAME.
BUT IT IS THAT.
YOU DON'T SAY AMERICA WITH AN
INTENSITY.
YOU DON'T SAY ENGLAND WITH AN
INTENSITY QUESTION, YOU KNOW?
YOU DON'T SAY THE ARMY WITH AN
INTENSITY.
>> Hannity: SEEMS FUNNY TO YOU
CONGRESSWOMAN?
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
FUNNY ABOUT 3,000 AMERICANS
KILLED ON 9/11 BY AL QAEDA OR OF
COURSE, HEZBOLLAH AND THE TERROR
AND THE DEATH AND THE MISERY
THAT OF COURSE THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
NOW, CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR ALSO
MINIMIZED TERRORISTS DURING A
SPEECH AT CARE, YOU MAY
REMEMBER, AND KEEP IN MIND, THIS
IS A FRENCH ISLAMIC GROUP.
LISTED AS UNINDICTED
COCONSPIRATORS IN THE HOLY LAND
FOUNDATION TERRORISM CASE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CARE WAS FOUNDED AFTER 9/11.
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
PEOPLE DID SOMETHING AND
THAT ALL OF US WERE STARTING TO
LOSE ACCESS TO OUR CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
>> Hannity: SOME PEOPLE DID
SOMETHING.
HIJACKED PLANES, RAN THEM INTO
BUILDINGS, FELL DOWN, HIT OUR
PENTAGON, AND A FIELD IN
PENNSYLVANIA, SOME THINGS?
OMAR CALLS ISRAEL EVIL.
SHE ACCUSES EVEN OBAMA AND TRUMP
OF BEING MURDERERS BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO 9/11 AND AL QAEDA, SOME
PEOPLE JUST DOING SOME THINGS.
SERIOUSLY?
LOOK HARD AT ONE OF THE FOUR
LEADERS OF TODAY IS RADICAL,
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
THE PEOPLE YOU SEE WITH THE MOST
INFLUENCE ON THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE CAMPAIGN.
IT SHOULD BE SHOCKING BUT WE'VE
SEEN IT COMING.
AND WE HAVE CYCLED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FURTHER AND
FURTHER TO THE LEFT AND NOW,
THERE ARE NO MORAL SCOOP
JACKSONS, MODERATE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE A NONEXISTENT PART OF
THE PARTY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I THINK
THEY MIGHT BE LITERALLY GONE
FOREVER.
THEY'VE BEEN REPLACED WITH
SOCIALIST WHO WANT THE
GOVERNMENT TO CONTROL YOUR
HEALTH CARE, OUR INDUSTRIES, OUR
BUSINESSES, OUR PAYCHECKS, OUR
LIVES, OUR CHOICES.
THEY WANT TO BE COMPLETELY OPEN
WITH BORDERS, AMNESTY FOR ALL,
UNFETTERED ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
AND BY THE WAY, FREE HEALTH CARE
TO BOOT FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
LATE-TERM ABORTION, EVEN DURING
BIRTH, AND SOMETIMES, AFTER
BIRTH.
I WOULD BE CALLED MURDER AND
UNFANTASIZED.
AND OF COURSE, THAT WE HAVE THE
GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH CALLS FOR
AN END TO ALL OIL GAS FROM A
NUMBER OF PLANES, NO MORE GAS
POWERED CARS AND TRUCKS,
GOVERNMENT FORCED REHAB OF EVERY
BUILDING IN AMERICA AND OF
COURSE, TAXPAYER-FUNDED
EDUCATION, INCOME, MEALS, AND
EVERYTHING ELSE FOR PEOPLE
WILLING AND UNWILLING TO WORK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO IMPROVE THIS
COUNTRY, THEY WANT TO REMAKE
THIS COUNTRY INTO SOMETHING WE
ALL KNOW WILL FAIL.
AND TONIGHT, THEY WANT TO
IMPEACH THE ONE PERSON THAT'S
BEEN STANDING IN THEIR WAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE NOT MADE IMPEACHMENT
CENTRAL TO MY ELECTION OR MY
TENURE.
BUT SINCE THE DAY THAT I HAVE
GOTTEN ELECTED, I HAVE SAID TO
PEOPLE, IT IS NOT --
IF YOU WILL BE IMPEACHED, BUT
WHEN.
SO IT IS TIME FOR US TO STOP
ALLOWING THIS PRESIDENT TO MAKE
A MOCKERY OUT OF OUR
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS TIME FOR US TO IMPEACH
THIS PRESIDENT.
SEE ONE IF YOU ARE PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION, YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION, SHE
DIDN'T ACTUALLY LIST ANYTHING
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHB
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHE
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHO
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHF
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHN
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACHE
THAT WOULD BE AN ACTUAL IMPEACH.
NO SURPRISE THERE.
THE RADICAL BASE OF THIS PARTY
DOES NOT CARE ABOUT THE WILL OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT VOTED IN
DONALD TRUMP AGAINST ALL ODDS
AND WITH THE DEEP STATE AGAINST
THEM.
CONTROL, 2020, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU, WE, THE PEOPLE, YOU
WILL DECIDE.
ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE UP YOUR
PERSONAL FREEDOMS TO A RADICAL
SOCIALIST GROUP OF DEMOCRATS?
DO YOU REALLY TRUST GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR EVERY NEED
FROM THE MINUTE YOU'RE GOING TO
THE MINUTE YOU DIE WHETHER
YOU'RE EVEN WILLING UNWILLING TO
WORK OR NOT?
ANYWAY, THEY VOTE TO IMPROVE THE
COUNTRY?